[Applaudissements]
alors je vous dis
à la fia un jour je venais de la radio
6h 9h virgin radio
je partais de chez moi était 3h30 du
matin j'étais persuadé que j'étais
boulanger l'époque on m'a présenté toile
oui je disais bon des fougasses a
diminué de l'essor du forez a pas de
problème moi rappelle sortait de chez
moi j'étais vraiment mieux par nos / ap
je vois les l'hiver l'été un petit matin
frileux pour aller voir mes vieux et
c'est vrai que j'arrive à la radio
virgin radio et là j'ai dit tiens il
faudra un mec qui aillent dans la rue
ils soient tous fous un peu folle et est
produite la radio a parlé de cyril à
bout parce qu'il s'appelle syrie l'air
et j'ai dit dans cette radio il ya de la
place pour kasserine change de prénom
ça m'arrange et pas pour des raisons
d'état civil ou bien qu'elles changent
le pré et là je le dis quel est ton
deuxième prénom à la la il m'a dit
raymond première action t'as pas de
chance mon deuxième réaction c'est comme
ça qu'on va trouver on va te retenir
n'appellera raymond c'est vrai il est
parti avec son petit chat nommé partis
la fleur au fusil et des duplex et sa
carte des quartiers cartonné et depuis
eh ben il est là le matin yves des
cacolac il soirée c'est pas magnifique
et tout le matin c'est des conneries
j'ai fait trois gardes à vue de
septembre jusqu'à avril la saison radio
je me s'arrête un peu avant j'ai fait
trois gardes à vue ce qu'en fait quand
je partais fermé des filles eux ce
qu'ils faisaient
il a appelé les flics pour toufik me
rejoindre sur place en usant d'un mec il
entre le bordel dans ce cas d'école et
batteur des poulets ils arrivent et non
mettre les gens sont vite l'intercepter
d'un camion blanc immatriculé tél
picard était arrivé ce jour 10 h
comprend pas m'as balancé il ya les
filles tu raccroches et regarda c'était
nous bush fait à chaque fois pour fuir
que je passais la police est nécessaire
il hanouna vous connaissez oui on
connaît il va désamorcer syrie alors moi
je fais je ne cause monsieur le
commissaire je ne cautionne pas du tout
voilà je vous le dis alors mais c'est
vrai quand ils les engueuler pas et que
ça partait pas en règle avec les
communes et commissaire
mais bon ça faudra le faire ça c'était
non ça c'est l'ancien moi c'était le
cogneur c'est fini tout ça c'est
derrière moi maintenant maintenant tu me
met une gifle je te dis merci
vous l'avez formé comme vous avez
vous-même avaient été formés parce que
vous aussi vous avez radio way